[Music]
um Who am I and why am I talking to
about groom I interned at our studio
over the last summer and worked on the
broom package and have since taken over
maintaining it so if there's any bugs
send them to me and I will try and fix
them and also the person who originally
wrote broom is at our studio conference
that's David Robinson so give him a big
shout out if you use broom at some point
um but I'm gonna talk to you about what
I'm calling the model representation
problem and how broom kind of alleviates
that to some degree if you want to
follow along with the slides these are
available online and you can download
them okay so anyway what is the model
representation problem so if you have
spent some time in a stat class or maybe
been reading some tutorials online you
will probably see things like this
somewhere here I've said okay there's
this why I and I'm using this little
tilde which means that this Y is a
random variable and it has a normal
distribution and so you can write this
down and if you've seen this before you
probably know what it means and
similarly you can kind of like pick one
normal distribution we have standard
notation for that and when we have like
a way to kind of represent factors of
parameters and you can write down
estimates so in my mind there's like
these kind of three key objects we have
like models and then we have like
individual fits for models we have
estimators which I don't wanna get into
too much but you can write these things
down in ways that other people
understand so that's the kind of
takeaway is that when you think of these
things in terms of math we have shared
notation and community standards for how
we write these things down
yeah so but in encode that's not the
case quite as much as one would hope and
so it's just a quick example so one
thing that you might imagine they might
want to do is if you have like some
classification model you might want to
get class probabilities for that model
okay but that's kind of hard to do
sometimes so most of the time you can
get class probabilities but the question
is how do you get class probabilities so
what I have here is some example that I
have stolen from max but you have these
different objects or models you'd like
to predict from and if you want to get
class probabilities there's all of these
different kind of interfaces right so
it's not a question of whether or not
you can do what you'd like to do it's
really a question of cognitive load I
don't want to have to remember all the
different type arguments when I want to
get class probabilities really I just
like to sit down and say remember one
thing and always get what I want
okay so what's happening is there's this
extra friction that takes time away from
being productive towards your end goal
which is really just like get the class
probabilities and then get done with
your job right okay so this is kind of
what I'm calling a model representation
problem is like we don't have a standard
way to represent these things okay and
broome is here to help
so broom is a package in by david
robinson and there's these kind of three
key ideas the idea is that we can take
these fits by fit what i mean is you
have some model and you like train a
model and you give me a trained model
back okay and we're gonna set there's
kind of like three key components in
this like broom philosophy and we're
gonna all of these components are going
to be tidy Tibbals and the reason are
gonna be tidy Tibbals is because we know
how to manipulate tables and so we can
use tools that we already know and there
isn't any kind of additional cognitive
load in working with those things so the
first type of information about a fit is
going to be like the components or the
parameters so if you have a linear
regression model you could think about
the regression coefficients so we're
gonna have a table that's gonna have all
the information about the regression
coefficients okay and that there's a s 3
generic that will provide that to us so
that'll be tidy and I'll show some
examples of how this works in just a
moment okay
the second generic is glance so glance
is going to always return a
with one row and the columns are going
to be different goodness-of-fit measures
so for example this could be things like
r-squared or log likelihood or bi C or
whatever kind of fancy version of you
know information criteria that a model
returns but it's a one row summary of
the entire model and then finally
there's going to be this third generic
that's augment and what augment does is
it says well you have this training data
set and each one of the rows in this
training data set influenced the final
model in some way so any of that
information about how it influenced the
final model is going to show up in
augment or if you have new data you can
also use it to get predictions on new
data in a kind of nice way okay so we'll
work through a kind of simple example
here first so suppose we have some data
we can simulate from a normal
distribution here and then we can get a
fit where now this normal fit object
here represents the Maclin maximum
likelihood estimator of the parameters
of this model okay so the question is
like if we didn't do anything like what
did this thing look like and if we look
at this normal fit object what we get is
a list then I've cut off some of it but
we have these things in here so there's
this uh we have our estimates the
maximum likelihood estimates themselves
and then we have their standard
deviations and the covariance and the
log likelihood this model okay so this
is like actually a pretty nice object
and you can work with it if you choose
to but the big issue is that if you go
to a different package it could look
really different right so as an example
of something that's gonna look really
different actually not as an example
that we'll get there in just a second
and we're gonna talk about linear models
first oh wow okay I'm out of order but
here's what happens when we want to tidy
this thing up right so we'd like to have
a table that represents these estimates
right so there's this normal fit and
what we can do is a be called tidy on it
broom is going to clean it up for us
okay so here we get is this table and
there's three columns and these column
names are pretty much always going to be
the same which is gonna be really nice
so we're gonna have this term column and
that's gonna tell us what parameter
we're actually working with we're gonna
have the estimate that's going to tell
us the actual value that we've
calculated that we think we should be
using and we'll get a standard error
which is going to address our
uncertainty uncertainty in that
parameter okay
so I told you that there were two other
generics that we can
to these objects so another one is
glance so for kind of a simple normal
model we only get some simple
Diagnostics here we see how many data we
fit to the total log likelihood and then
these other kind of criteria there isn't
actually an augment defined in broome at
the moment for these universe tribution
but you could think about these if you
wanted to like you could probably define
like a log likelihood contribution if
you wanted to think about that okay so
let's think about a slightly more
involved model where this might start
becoming more clear like how it'll be
useful in practice so if you want to
follow along on your computer you can
this is you only need these two lines so
we're going to create this OLS fit
object which is gonna be OLS estimators
for the linear model okay and I can't
actually print this out on a slide
because this object is really big and
complicated but it's interesting to look
into yourself if you kind of want to or
if you just want to be like intimidated
by how crazy the internals are cuz I
still have no clue how it works okay so
but then when you tidy it you get
something that's a lot easier to work
with you just get this table okay so
here we have the term again the term is
each one of our linear regression
coefficients and we have this estimate
but now there's some additional
information about linear models that we
didn't have before so we have these
statistics from T tests and associated
p-values if you wanted you could also
get confidence intervals there is a
argument to tidy that will give you
those confidence intervals when you
glance at this you also get a lot of
information so some of the metrics that
you're gonna get you're gonna get like R
squared and adjusted R squared here
Sigma is the error variance which is
going to give you some measure of how
uncertain predictions from this model
are going to be and so on and so forth
and what exactly you get out is going to
depend on the particular model that you
put in but the the column names are
consistent so if you want to like figure
out how to get this information from one
model or another you don't have to
remember what the internals of those two
models look like you can just tidy or
glance them and then always just access
that one column that you care about okay
finally I told you that there's this
third generic augment so if you call
augment and you don't have any
additional data you can pass data in to
augment but if you don't pass any data
it's gonna route around in the model
object and find the training data for
your model so in this case what it's
done is it's found that I used three
columns from the original empty cars
data set HP and
and cylinder and it's gonna put those
into a data frame and then it's gonna
add additional information about each
one of these observations so here each
row is an observation we can see that
there's a dot fitted column which is
going to be our actual prediction from
the model there's a dot SE fit which is
the standard error of that prediction
and then so on and so forth so for
linear regression there's a bunch of
kind of additional measures that we can
add in here um but there's these are all
kinda like training data level summaries
okay so that's like the big picture of
what Broome does and now I'd like to
show you how I end up using Broome and
practice so the first thing that I do is
I use it a lot when I want to do like a
quick and dirty reporting tool so if you
are familiar with the knitter cable
function it's fantastic it takes a data
frame and then no matter how kind of
what you're outputting to it just gives
you like a nice table and so if you can
get your model into a table which is
exactly what Tidy is gonna do most of
the time you can report it really fast
so this is like my super quick and dirty
I don't want to just like barf our
output into a homework document or
something like that so I'll use this
kind of combination the next thing that
you can do is you can use broom to
compare different models by using this
glance generic on a list of models all
at once so what I've done here is I've
said well let's put three different
models in a list I'm going to call them
fit one fit two and fit three and in
this case I'm adding more predictors at
each step okay and then I'm going to use
this tool from the per package called
map DF and what that's going to do is
it's going to apply the glance generic
to each one of these models and then
it's going to put them all into a data
frame together and I'm going to arrange
it by the AIC so if I look at the result
now I have a summary for each one of my
models and in this case it looks like
AIC is the best model in terms that fit
three is the best model in terms of AIC
I think that you can also plot this
immediately for a really nice visual
model comparison okay by far my favorite
use case for Broome is checking multiple
linear regression so I told you that if
you use augment you're going to get the
residuals
and one of the things you might want to
do when you're doing some sort of
regression is you might want to take the
residuals and compare them to each of
your predictors and look at these
partial residual plots and if you're
going to see any kind of systematic
deviations there that might indicate
some sort of model misfit so if I want
to do a visual check for model misfit I
have about ten lines of code here and
it's going to produce the following plot
so that's it and now I can look at these
residuals and see if there's any
patterns here so if I kind of eyeball
this I wouldn't be too concerned in this
case but it's a nice way to do quick and
easy Diagnostics okay so finally I'm
gonna work through kind of a more
extended example I don't actually have
the time so if someone could let me know
how much I have left that would be great
um but I'm gonna work through this kind
of more in an example which is where I
think the real power of broom comes in
which is when you want to work with
multiple models at once okay
so suppose we have this data this is the
empty cars data again I'm sorry if
you've seen this 100 times but if we
want to think about the miles per gallon
and wait we could say well let's use a
model here but we don't want to do a
linear model we could say this really
looks like there's some sort of inverse
relationship let's do some sort of like
nonlinear least squares so we could say
well let's just use this model so let's
it there's like some inverse
relationship with weight the particular
model here is not particularly important
but we could say well let's use this
model and maybe we'd like to fit this a
bajillion times on bootstrap datasets to
see what the uncertainty in these
parameters K and B is okay so to do this
the first thing that we're going to use
is we're gonna use the our sample
package and we're gonna create bootstrap
datasets in this case we're gonna create
a hundred bootstrap datasets and what
we're gonna get is we're gonna get this
Tibble that has a bunch of nested
objects so when you start looking at
kind of these are sample stuff there's
you might wonder what's going on so you
have this split object and so this split
is gonna have two kind of data sets
contained in it it's gonna have the
bootstrap data set and the held-out data
set and then there's going to be this ID
column and so the idea is that we're
going to use mutate together with per
map to add new list columns of models
and work with those new list columns of
models
and a general strategy that works really
well in these kind of circumstances is
you figure out how to do something on
one resampled data set so what I've done
here is there's a function in R that
will let me fit a nonlinear least
squares and it's called n LS and so n LS
is going to need three arguments I have
to kind of define the formula that I
want to use so in this case that's
exactly the formula from the slides
couple before and I have to tell it the
data I want to use so in this case
there's that split object from my
bootstraps data frame and I'd like to
use the analysis function to get the
training set out of there and finally
because it's a kind of different model
than usual I have to give it some sort
of initial parameters which don't really
matter here so this is the helper
function that's going to solve this
problem for me on one data set so now
I'd like to generalize this which I can
just do with math so now I take my
bootstrap datasets and I'm going to
mutate map so now I'm going to fit a
bootstrap data set on each one of these
resample data sets and I'm gonna do the
second thing where now I have each one
of these fit models and I'm going to
tidy each one of these fit models here
so now what I've done is in this first
row I have a data set I have an ID that
kind of corresponds to which data that
is and then I have an s3 object that's
my actual model object which is living
in this column and then I'm gonna have a
nested table which has my tidied
coefficients so at first glance this
kind of structure can seem really
intimidating because you have all of
these like nested hierarchical
structures um but this is kind of where
you want to think about you want to end
up here and then there's a magical
function from tidy R that's gonna
flatten this out into something that we
can actually work with in an intuitive
way and that's the uh nest in this case
if I on nest on coefficient info I'm
going to go back on slide really fast
so coefficient info is this list of
tables by unnecessary de bout my
coefficients so now if I want to plot
this to visualize uncertainty this is
just a one liner or two liner and ggplot
okay five liner but then you throw it in
ggplot2 and you just can see this right
away so i haven't done a whole bunch of
bootstraps here
but hopefully the the idea is that the
workflow is very convenient okay there's
a kind of one last use case that you can
use here so suppose we wanted to do the
same thing but we'd like to visualize
the uncertainty in our predictions in
that case what we're going to do is work
with the Augmented data sets so we're
going to apply the same strategy we
already have a table of fit models we're
going to map augment over those fit
models and what we're going to get again
is going to be this nested table with a
bunch of predictions and then we can
unnecessary dictions and ggplot them
right away
and that looks like this so now you have
a bunch of non linear fits that you're
visualizing all at once okay so that's
what I use Brumos for personally there's
a bunch of documentation on how to use
broom we just released broom 0.50 that's
kind of the end of the summer so there's
a bunch of information on new releases
and new tie tiers that were supported
there you can also learn how to
implement these methods yourself we have
some standards that you can use so that
your broom functions or the your
tighters is what we call them what will
behave like other broom functions which
is what you really want to do to
decrease the cognitive load which is the
goal in the end right so there's a
website with all this documentation and
I'm also happy to answer questions or
help with pull requests or anything at
any time so I've got my contact
information up here as well thank you
[Applause]
cool if you go to my Twitter I should
have just tweeted out okay so thanks
Alex
we have time for a couple questions
maybe stand up and wave at me if you do
have one yeah okay back here
hear me can you hear me anybody okay so
since you're a bootstrapping with the
Tibbles that making it extremely
efficient timewise okay so there's two
things have to think about in terms of
the efficiency for these things the
first is like the data are you gonna
create a bunch of copies of the data and
the answer is no max has implemented
this in a way so that you're not going
to create excessive copies of the data
you're gonna have to create a little bit
of so I think the examples like if you
like bootstrap and you have 50 bootstrap
datasets you're gonna have like maybe
three times as much storage space as
originally what you're really going to
get hit with in terms of inefficiency is
going to be the models themselves so
most modeling functions in are they
actually save the data that they were
fit on and that gets big really fast so
it really depends on how kind of clean
the modeling packages but that's
normally not at your mercy so if you're
running into kind of space issues one
kind of standard thing you could do is
you can define a helper function to fit
the model figure out what you actually
need from that and then try and throw
away as much junk as possible and kind
of keep that like pared down object I
think we have time for one more question
since I great talk
can you just in a few sentences say what
it takes to implement new tied ears yeah
normally it's about like five lines of
Tidy verse code in terms of like effort
so like five lines of Tidy verse code
and effort the biggest thing is making
sure that you're meeting the kind of
conventions so if you break with the
convention that it doesn't actually do
any good for anybody so there's a lot of
documentation I need to update that to
some extent but this link that I have in
the slides here should work you through
everything you need to do so I would say
like maybe fifteen minutes to read
through that and then hopefully thirty
minutes or less to create a custom one
on your own I think we can't actually do
one more quick question everybody has
I have a I have a love-hate relationship
with the boot package but one thing that
I like about it is that it's got support
for computing different types of
confidence intervals that have better
properties that you would that you would
like in them so I was wondering if if
these tools have anything like that
implemented or it's just kind of
percentile confidence intervals and that
sort of thing so I didn't actually show
a confidence interval example what I
visualized up on the board was the the
entire sampling distribution so if you
can I would that's what my
recommendation is is to like a look at
the whole sampling distribution but when
you're working with our sample it's kind
of low level infrastructure so if you're
going to do calculations across all of
those coefficients that once you'll need
to implement that method yourself or max
has a comment as well
oh yeah there's fancy stuff there's like
six three two coming yeah so there's
fancy stuff coming they'll be really
cool
[Music]